to say you don't know me and you've
never been with me when you've
definitely been with me when everybody's
seen you with me when I have pictures
and videos of you with me come on
Travis Scott shuts down claims he
cheated on Kylie Jenner calling the
whole thing weird on Saturday Travis
Scott made a rare statement about his
relationship slamming rumors that he was
unfaithful to the mother of his two
children after Instagram model rojin
Carr shared photos and videos from a
music video shoot with the rapper last
week the musician posted to his insta
story writing that there's a lot of
weird going on adding that an Uninvited
person was sneaking photos on what was
supposed to be a closed set for a music
video he was directing quote I'm saying
this for the last time I don't know this
person I've never been with this person
so please stop with the continuous cyber
games and the fictional storytelling all
that comes after the model shared snaps
to her private Instagram story showing
Travis on set Regine sarcastically
captioned one of the posts I'm directing
Avi next to a winking emoji and
following Travis's statement rojin
responded to his claims that he didn't
know her okay so what We're Not Gonna Do
Is We're not gonna lie on me because
I've been good I posted whatever story
you guys wanted me to post I
pretended I didn't know you went along
with whatever narrative you guys wanted
to no matter how much like I got from it
but to say you don't know me and you've
never been with me when you've
definitely been with me when everybody's
seen you with me when I have pictures
and videos of you with me come on
commands there and I was invited to that
video to you guys I would knock I
personally do not go anywhere unless I'm
invited there she even alleged that she
was with him earlier this year on
Valentine's Day I saw you I ran out the
door and you had every single girl I
know blowing me up like trav's asking
for you to come back are we pretending
that didn't happen too like come on you
cheat on that every single [ __ ] night
the whole [ __ ] City sees it
don't do this well the sicko mode rapper
shut all that down too sharing this
since deleted snap from his Valentine's
Day celebration with Kylie seemingly
take in on February 14th at 809 PM
writing if he wasn't at this table on
v-day then you wasn't with me
imma cover fours got these others shook
Kylie and Travis rekindled their romance
in 2020 after a brief split in 2019. the
two who share a four-year-old daughter
stormy welcomed their son in February I
feel like with my second you just like
anticipate everything and you know
what's gonna happen and you've done it
before so it's I feel like I was a lot
more present
this time back in August the source told
ET that things between them were going
super well adding that they have really
mastered being together quote he is
always going above and beyond as a dad
and as a partner and Kylie appreciates
his dedication to her and their little
ones
[Music]
thank you